es el nombre de quien tendrá la difícil
tarea de sustituir a yasin arder como
primera ministra de Nueva Zelanda tras
su dimisión
fue designado por los diputados
laboristas y dirigirá su partido hacia
las próximas elecciones generales de
octubre el futuro jefe de gobierno de 44
años expresó su satisfacción estoy
deseando comenzar a trabajar Me siento
enérgico y entusiasta ha sido aclamado
por su mandato de casi dos años como
ministro encargado para la respuesta a
la pandemia de Kobe 19 y es ampliamente
considerado en su país como un político
experimentado con más de 14 años en el
parlamento
jacinda arder figura Mundial de la
política progresista sorprendió a sus
compatriotas tras anunciar su retiro la
ex primera ministra Helen Clark afirmó
que arder se había enfrentado a un nivel
de odio sin precedentes en el país una
declaración confirmada por el próximo
Primer Ministro
creo que ha habido mucha virulencia y
quiero reconocer que algunos políticos
han padecido de ella más que otros
nuestra actual primera ministra Hacienda
arder ha sido objeto de comportamientos
absolutamente intolerables e
inaceptables
muy popular durante sus dos mandatos
arden Dios sin embargo caer su índice de
aprobación en los últimos meses debido
según los analistas al aumento de la
delincuencia y a que no ha conseguido
transformar el país reduciendo
drásticamente la pobreza